hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner trocken
hält auch heute gibt es wieder ein
advents video von mir das ist jetzt
schon das letzte wir haben den vierten
advent heute und schaut mal rein für
heute bei mir was bestellt hat ich bin
da soll ich noch heute eine typische
weihnachtsgedicht geht so habe ich die
schwebe bosse von kraus von der alte
komisch ich habe auf der wein geachtet
sehr überall trat auf der pfanne spritze
japan war ich wurde goldene glühwein der
hitze ich habe alles versorgung hab
gelacht da hatte christkind große augen
gemacht und hat grube hat sein du alte
gesell bewegt eine komische gestellt du
musst die kinder bringen die äpfel und
nüsse damit sie den nächsten jahr auch
brav sein müsse unvergessen der sac und
der rote dazu habe ich große was glaubst
du denn was glaubst denn du so gehen ich
bin nicht amputiert es ist alles noch da
guck mal unter kam auch damit sie
demnächst ja auch brav sein müsse
scheiße voll verkackt ich war noch mal
ich bin nicht amputiert ist alles noch
da und das ist mit voll mit weihnachts
tralala route kind oder böse gehen ich
bin sicher dass ich für alles was finde
es war gut für ein papier für mich ich
muss von der seele wisse wie man macht
so richtiger leckerbissen so ein
weihnachtsmenü das sollten wir auch
schmecken
weil ich mir sonst ein steak in der
toaster stecke logik scheißegal aber gut
ne also schöne weihnachten und schöner
trend
wie wasser danke für deine bestellung
natürlich hält sich da gerne weiter und
zeigt ihr über diese leckerbissen machen
kann und ein schönes weihnachten kann
wie sie da für dich da allerdings und
das kann ich das angehende
deutschlehrerin sage du brauchst einen
deutschkurs ganz einfach die grammatik
das stimmt einfach nicht
aber was an das thema auch noch hin und
als menü habe ich mir überlegt dass es
als vorspeise pro skater gibt mit
tomaten
dass ich aber eher so auf meine art ich
mag es nämlich ganz gerne mit etwas mehr
kräuter zeige ich euch gleich zum
hauptgang geht's lang lachse mit
kräuterkruste und herzen kartoffeln und
alles bisher gibt es weihnachtliche
nicht so das ist allerdings nicht hier
in diesem video sondern es gibt es in
einem anderen video was ich ihr euch
gleich verlinken werde und dieses menü
passt natürlich perfekt zu weihnachten
aber auch zu silvester aber auch ohne
diese zwei anderen könnte das menü
natürlich jederzeit woanders auch kochen
ich bin gerade diese lang wachsen
richtig genial pro skater gibt es bei
uns wirklich ganz oft und die herzogin
kartoffeln sind wirklich richtig aus der
feinschmecker
ich zeige euch jetzt zuerst einmal wie
man es besser macht also die vorspeise
und da gibt es wirklich ganz viele
verschiedene rezepte tradition geht das
so gemacht dass man das brot nimmt das
kostet und dann mit etwas knoblauch und
olivenöl bestreichen
damit ist aber ein bisschen zu
langweilig hier steige ich euch gleich
wie ich meine knoblauchbutter herstelle
ich mache es nämlich mit ein bisschen
butter und olivenöl weil ich das so
etwas aromatischer finde und etwas
würziger und ich sage ich es einfach mal
die zutaten für das prostata und zeit
mich dann wie es weitergeht
für die knoblauchbutter braucht ihr etwa
60 gramm butter 2 knoblauchzehen gerne
auf 3 und ein paar kräuter und zwar habe
ich jetzt hier erstmal halben teelöffel
salz und filter teelöffel pfeffer etwa
halben teelöffel basilikum und halben
teelöffel oregano und etwa fährt telefon
cayennepfeffer und dann braucht ihr noch
etwas olivenöl
ich würde mal sagen so etwa 40
milliliter und das ganze werde ich jetzt
gleich auf diese baguette streichen und
die butter könnt ihr dann ganz normal in
den mixer herstellen oder auch in noch
so tief berühren
ich mache jetzt einfach im thermomix
weil es schnell geht da gebe ich meine 2
knoblauchzehen rein und lass dir einmal
schön klein hexel
dann kommt da die butter mit rein die
kräuter und auch gleich das olivenöl und
das passiert einfach schön verrückt und
je nachdem wieviel paprikapulver eingibt
wird daneben rohstoffs gefällt mir
eigentlich auch immer ganz gut aber da
sie zu einem scharfen cayennepfeffer da
habe ich da etwas weniger rein
das baguette schaltet ihr dann noch
entscheiden
das darf ruhig etwas älteres baguette
sein und zwar schneide ich das so in
etwa 1,5 zentimeter dicke streifen und
dann wird es mit dieser creme
bestreichen und die butter die können
richtig gut vorbereiten
die könnte dann auch wenn sie übrig
bleibt einfach in so ein kleines gefäß
geben mit deckel und dem kühlschrank
lagern
die könnte da wirklich über mehrere
wochen lagern und die kann gut
vorbereitet werden das heißt es könnte
auch schon einen tag vorher machen und
einfach auf zimmertemperatur bringen
damit sie eben so schön streichfähig
bleibt und dann habt ihr das ja ganz
schnell gemacht und gibt die einfach auf
mein backblech und werde sie bei 220
grad
solange rösten bis so richtig schön
goldbraun sind in der zwischenzeit könnt
ihr schon mal die tomaten vorbereiten
ich mache es ja nur eine kleine portion
deswegen nehme ich eine tomate
da passt auch ganz gut etwas rucola mit
dazu und für das dressing braucht ihr
balsamico-essig balsamico creme das ist
so eine dickflüssigere creme die wird
aus balsamico essig gewonnen
etwas olivenöl und ich habe hier noch
salz pfeffer und oregano und eine prise
zucker
die tomaten müssen dann in würfel
geschnitten würden dazu entferne ich
erst mal her
den strunk und wenn ihr nicht möchte
dass es später alles zu flüssig wird
dann entfernt ihr hier noch das innere
könnte er weiter verwehrt
tomaten werden dann gewürfelt das mache
ich wieder hier in meinem gerät
und jetzt kommt das dressing an und zwar
nehme ich immer hat das verhältnismäßig
nämlich eine portion balsamico eine
portion balsamico creme zwei portionen
olivenöl und daneben die kräuter mittel
und hier könnte wie gesagt nur rucola
mit reingeben den einfach bis jetzt der
kleinen so sieht es dann aus wenn es
richtig schön gerüstet ist
und da kommt jetzt diese tomaten master
drauf
dekorieren könnt ihr das ganze mit etwas
balsamico kre
da passt natürlich ganz toll wieder
etwas parmesan dazu
und fertig ist die vorspeise die
vorspeise ist jetzt vorbereitet und
jetzt zeige ich euch gleich wie es zum
hauptgang geht und zwar werde ich jetzt
die kartoffeln und das lammfilet
zubereiten und stanze gibt's bei mir ein
kleiner york stippich weil ich das jetzt
einfach nacheinander auf meinem blog auf
www konzertorten welt.de könnt ihr aber
wenn ich es menü in dieser reihenfolge
machen wollt die schritte so sehen wie
sie ebenso bereitet werden dass er eben
zeit sparend kommen könnte
für das fleisch braucht ihr folgende
zutaten
ich habe jetzt hier fehl am platze und
zwar etwa ein kilo
ich nehme langeweile sind ziemlich
feines fleisch ist und auch das zartes
filet vom lamm
früher mochte ich lang eigentlich nicht
aber seitdem ich diese zubereitung kenne
mag ich wirklich sehr und das solltet
ihr auch wirklich auf qualität achten
ihr könnt aber beispielsweise auch
lammkotelett nehmen wobei ich wie gesagt
die des landtags am besten finde
und er erkennt es an der farbe das ist
ein helles rot und diese fat stückchen
sind schön weiß daran erkennt ihr dass
es ein frisches produkt ich und das ist
eben auch ein junges tier ist dann
braucht ihr zwei teelöffel senf preises
egal welchen senf ihr nehmt ob grob oder
mittel oder schaf oder extra scharf dann
braucht ihr salz und pfeffer und für
diese kräuterkruste die ich jetzt gleich
machen werde braucht ihr eine
knoblauchzehe einen esslöffel kräuter
das ist jetzt bei mir oregano einen
halben teelöffel salz eine prise pfeffer
ihr braucht wahl müsse die habe ich
jetzt schon etwas klein gemacht das sind
aber auch noch stückchen drin und zwar
braucht jeder 40 gramm 60 gramm butter
30 gramm paares an käse den habe ich
jetzt auch schon geschrieben und ihr
braucht 80 gramm semmelbrösel und ein
paar meter an käse den hab ich
geschrieben den kauf ich nämlich immer
am stück so richtig schön frisch zuerst
einmal werde ich jetzt die kräuter
panade zu bereiten
dafür gebe ich jetzt die semmelbrösel
den paar messe hand die butter die
walnüsse und die kräuter hier rein und
da drücke ich jetzt noch eine
knoblauchzehe mit rein
ihr könnt aber auch fein hacken
ist eigentlich besser für knoblauch und
damit das ganze verrührt und ich mach
das einfach mit den händen weil es so
viel schneller geht
ich nehme aber handschuhe weil meine
hände richtig stoff stinken und soll
dann so eine richtig schöne krümelige
masse sein die aber auch fest bleibt
wenn ihr sie zusammen drückt für das
fleisch nehme ich mir einfach eine ganz
normale pfanne und gibt da etwas öl rein
das ist ganz normales
geschmacksneutralen öl die pfanne ist
schon heiß und da kommen jetzt meine
fleischstücke rein und müssen davon
jeder seite etwa eine minute gebraten
werden richtig schön heiß
unter wenig fleisch
und da kommt jetzt etwas salz und
pfeffer drauf
und dann wird es von beiden seiten mit
dem senf eingestrichen und senf hilft
einfach dass es fleisch richtig schön
zart und weich wird und außerdem gibt es
dem ganzen noch einen richtig schönen
geschmack das sollten sie nicht zu dick
machen damit es nicht so zu dominant
wert und dann gebe ich das fleisch und
mein backblech mit backpapier diese
kräuter panade drauf die dürfte nicht zu
dick machen
ich werde jetzt aber mal nur zwei zu
bereiten
da es aber zu viel hunger und so kommt
es dann bei 190 grad für etwa 15 minuten
in den ofen
so sieht man fleisch ist nach dem backen
aus und wir mögen das immer ganz gern
etwas medium das erkennt ihr auch daran
wenn ihr hier das fleisch drückt dass es
noch schön weich ist also da gibt es
auch so ein trick dass man das mit der
hand messen kann und zwar wenn ihr
daumen und zeigefinger zusammendrückt
und hierauf drückt dann ist das ziemlich
weich mit dem mittelfinger ist es etwas
härter das heißt fleischig etwas durch
und wenn ihr mit dem ringfinger macht
ist es ganz durch und dem kleinen finger
ist eigentlich schon zweimal tot und wir
mögen sie eben ganz gern medium deswegen
wenn ich hier drücke und es schön weich
ist es so wie wenn ich hier drücke und
es hier weiter
also wenn ihr das jetzt verstanden habt
ganz wichtig gescherzt das ist egal bei
welchem fleisch das macht das fleisch
muss jetzt erst mal 5 minuten ruhen
damit sich der fleischsaft wieder schön
verteilt und es eben nicht später alles
raus druck und ihr könnt diese panade
auf jedes fleisch machen also auch auf
rinder fleisch oder auf hähnchen das ist
ganz egal ich finds am leckersten auf
langweilig lang ganz gerne mag aber auch
auf allen anderen fleischsorten passt es
richtig gut
wie essen das fleisch und diese
kartoffeln sei gerne mit einem joghurt
tipp und ich nehme dazu immer so einen
fertigen joghurt und stichfest das
typische joghurt aber ihr könnt ja auch
ganz gut im griechischen sport nehmen
daher hat zehn prozent fett und staffel
nehme ich mir etwa 200 gramm
dann kommt da etwa ein halber teelöffel
salz mit dazu etwas pfeffer und dann
noch eine knoblauchzehe einmal alles
verrührt und das war's dann auch schon
müsste nur noch abschmecken ob noch salz
pfeffer oder knoblauch fehlt und das
war's und das ist schon richtig leckere
tipp da wirklich gut zu der fleischsorte
passt
für die kartoffeln braucht ihr 500 g
geschälte kartoffeln 50 gramm butter
etwas salz 2 und etwas muskatnuss hier
vorne habe ich schon mal wasser
aufgekocht und da gebe ich jetzt etwa
einem teelöffel salz mitteilen damit ich
da gleich die karten unseren kochen kann
die kartoffel müssen jetzt in würfel
geschnitten werden und dazu schneidet
jetzt erst mal anschreiben und entweder
schneidet ihr sie dann in stifte und
dann entwürfe und wenn es schneller
gehen soll nehmt euch hier so ein gerät
das schneidet mir das richtig schön in
würfel
und dann geht das ganze in eurer salz
pfeffer und da gebe ich jetzt den deckel
drauf und lass das kochen das dauert so
etwa 15 minuten bis die kartoffeln jetzt
weich sind
und ich habe die deswegen in würfel
geschnitten weil sie so eben schneller
sind weil er die kartoffel stücke dann
eben kleiner sind meine kartoffeln sind
jetzt gar das kann man ganz einfach mit
einer gabel erkennen wenn man mit der
rhein sticht dann sind die stückchen
richtig weil und da werde ich jetzt
einmal das wasser abgießen
die kartoffeln habe ich abgegossen und
möchte sie jetzt durch pressen chips
auch ganz kurz abkühlen lassen und gibt
es jetzt durch eine kartoffelpresse
durch ihr könnt aber auch
kartoffelstampf nehmen
und dann kommt jetzt hier noch im warmen
zustand die butter mit rein und auch
gleich den muskel und etwas salz und
natürlich auch pfeffer und zwei gelb und
es wird jetzt alles schön verrührt und
dann fühle ich mir das ganze in einem
großen spritzbeutel mit großer stern
köhler
und dann wird es einfach auf einem blech
gespritzt bzw öffnet folie ihr könnt es
aber auch ganz gut mit einem latten
machen aber so werden sie eben schönere
kartoffel
zu sehen die kartoffeln jetzt aus und
die kommt es bei der gleichen temperatur
bis fleisch in den ofen und zwar für
zehn minuten
das heißt ich schrieb die kartoffeln
rein wenn das fleisch etwa fünf minuten
schon drin ist so sehen übrigens die
kartoffeln aus wenn sie dann aus dem
ofen rauskommen und jetzt zeige ich euch
noch mich das ganze sehr wäre und zwar
gebe ich das fleisch hier auf den teller
und ich sage jetzt auch mal wie das
jetzt bei mir durchgebracht packern ist
also hier seht ihr richtig schön rosa
und die kartoffeln gebe ich dir einfach
nur bis an den rand und dann kommt da
auf dieser knobloch situation
ich hoffe dass ich dieses mio gefallen
hat wenn ja macht ganz gerne nach ich
würde mich natürlich über kommentare und
bewertungen freuen
alle weiteren infos und die genauen
mengenangaben findet ihr unter
www.starbett.de dort könnt ihr auch
alles weitere finden den shop blog und
über mich seite und ich wünsche euch
noch einen ganz schönen tag wünsche euch
natürlich auch frohe weihnachten falls
wir uns vorher gehört und das sehen und
ich wünsche dir alles alles gute